c'est au festival de jazz en 1988 que le
public montréalais découvre john est
clair il créé toute une surprise est en
flammes une foule record de 50000
spectateurs devant le complexe
desjardins
du jamais vu en huit ans d'existence du
festival celui qu'on appelle le zoulou
blanc et déjà mondialement connu non
seulement pour sa musique un mélange de
pop et des sud africains mais aussi
parce qu'il est un militant anti
apartheid
infatigable pendant des années sur
toutes les tribunes
il appelle à la libération de nelson
mandela et à la fin du régime de
ségrégation raciale dans son pays
l'afrique du sud johnny clegg reviendra
plusieurs fois à montréal
atteint d'un cancer du pancréas il
donnera son dernier concert dans la
métropole
lors de sa tournée d'adieu en 2017
en 2007 il donnait une entrevue en
français à nos collègues de la radio
montréal c'est un lieu très spécial pour
moi parce que j'ai arrive ici en 1988 et
j'y apporte une grand message de la
lutte contre l'apartheid
né en angleterre de parents sud africain
blanc johnny clegg passe presque toute
son enfance et sa vie d'adulte en
afrique du sud ou très jeune il se lie
d'amitié avec les enfants des
domestiques noires de sa famille sa mère
une chanteuse d'origine juive polonaise
qui sera plus tard aussi sa productrice
lui donne une éducation
exceptionnellement libéral peu courante
à l'époque dans les milieux blanc de son
pays
en quarante ans de carrière johnny clegg
à métisser de façon unique les
traditions zouloues et la culture
occidentale
celui qui disait affectionner tout
autant la danse que la guitare et le
chant a vendu plus de 5 millions de 10
plus connu de ses chansons restent
asimbonanga
c'est en anglais son refrain en zoulou
elle avait provoqué tout un scandale en
afrique du sud
elle est devenue un véritable hymne anti
apartheid qu'on chante encore partout
aujourd'hui elle a fait de son auteur
une sorte de héros national ici
alexandra schatz caf radio canada
montréal